okay let's bring out Steve Kornacki - as
a palate cleanser Steve he runs the big
board as national political
correspondent for NBC News and MSNBC his
book is the red and the blue the 1990s
and the birth of political tribalism
Steve Kornacki is over here
[Applause]
what a pleasure to meet you I love
watching you because you know everyone
has an opinion as you can see and you're
the guy who doesn't I love that you're
Joe Friday just the facts ma'am well
thank you and I really appreciate that
and also your enthusiasm for the subject
of politics is so infectious and so real
and I wondering where do you get that my
father was a news guy and ready yeah
that's where I got it where did you get
it you know III election nice there's
always something at a young age I kind
of I filed a governor's race when I was
a kid in Massachusetts and the campaign
was fascinating but the election night
just watching it was the map of
Massachusetts it was 1990 it was a very
close race and watching the political
character of each town and city get
revealed almost like pieces in a puzzle
and at the end of it I felt like I was
in a sixth grade but I felt like I
understood a little bit about the state
I lived in and I try to take that to
every election I cover well so so this
one the cycles changed so quickly that
you know between the time the show
started and now maybe you have a whole
bunch of different information but like
I was feeling pretty good about the
Senate only like a week ago and now I
feel like there's a waste of money
wasn't it I mean yeah look if the if the
election were held tomorrow everybody
went and voted tomorrow I don't think
there's a scenario where the Democrats
get the Senate in so important defendant
it's I mean this now this is the thing
though I think there could be two tracks
that are developing here because think
about it this way there are three races
the Democrats have to win one of them to
get a shot at the Senate those three
races would be North Dakota Tennessee or
Texas must win one if you're a Democrat
to be in the game if you get shot out of
all three you're out now the reason the
Senate seems to be fading from the
picture for Democrats is they've gotten
bad to devastating news in all of those
states this week but think about there's
those states and the political character
of them North Dakota
Trump won it by 36 points Tennessee by
26 Texas by 9 control of the Senate is
being decided in Trump country in deep
red throw Trump States now flip it over
the House Democrats need a net gain of
23 seats to pick up the house
how many districts are there in the
house that our Republican held but that
voted for Hillary Clinton in 2016 the
answer is 25 so the math gets different
in the house when you start talking
about where we've seen the Democratic
energy it could work in the house and be
useless in the Senate useless in the
Senate that's my takeaway there could be
anything I mean we really don't know and
also it's so I mean this is a lot about
what your book is about where the
tribalism are started I feel like it's
so tribal now that in years past you
could go against someone in your own
party if they did something outrageous
and now everything is just my party my
color it's almost like the Crips and the
Bloods same colors right listen there
was a poll taken in 2016
there was a poll taken to 2016 that
essentially asked people you know would
you be upset if your son or daughter
married somebody from the other
political party right and for Democrats
and Republicans both answer both
answered yes over 60% I mean those are
numbers used to get for interracial
marriage right and that is how personal
the definition of parties become for
people this idea of red and blue we
think red and blue have been with us
forever or at least all of modern
political history they really originated
on election night 2000 the first time we
looked at an election map in a
generation and saw a close race and we
didn't just see a close race we saw deep
divisions that were regional cultural
demographic and they've been with us
since you blame Newt Gingrich for a lot
of this and that made me happy I don't
and that was right after a climate the
Clarence Thomas I I always thought it
was the Clarence Thomas that really
kicked Bork and then into Clarence and
that really kicked off this new era
where the other party the other people
are the other two where we get to this
point now where it's very very
frightening I I'm frightened because
Trump talks every day about us in some
way the enemy of the people is the press
talks about that we're at an angry mob I
mean when you talk about angry mob that
sounds like he's setting up at some
point you know we're gonna need martial
law until we find out what the hell is
going on
you see anyway back from that she's well
is it so we mentioned Newt Gingrich
where I think the origin of all of this
comes from is the thing that Gingrich
got early on his career ahead of almost
anybody else in politics was that the
future of politics was in nationalizing
politics and that media was evolving in
a way that was conducive to that and
Gingrich was living in a world in the
70s and 80s on his way up where
Republicans were dominating him
presidential election I mean Reagan got
49 states and 84 Bush forty and eighty
eight so the Gingrich theory was simple
you nationalize politics you make every
Democrat in everybody's backyard look
just like this national party they've
been rejecting you win everything in the
media you know the proliferation of
cable news all of the other sources of
information Gingrich found a way to
nationalize through this expanding media
but what happened was he gets to his
highest moment in 1994 gets the Congress
for the first time in 40 years and
politics is nationalized now people
start looking at the Republican Party
differently they start looking at as the
party of Newt Gingrich a party that now
has a heavy Christian conservative
influence in it and maybe didn't before
and Gingrich was half right in his
vision of politics basically half the
country was roughly was gonna respond to
his version but the other half was gonna
respond against it and I think that's
where we are in politics now it's as
much about what you and your party are
for as who you are against in who is
against you